[Music]
they say if you listen carefully enough
the past whispers to you
i love the enigma of dumbledore
dumbledore is such an iconic character
and to be able to explore a story that
looks into his past is amazing
the world as we know it is coming undone
this time we really get to explore
the mysteries and secrets of his past
and we're peeking into the complicated
relationship he has with his old friend
and great foe
gaelic grindelwald
[Music]
dumbledore is filled with regret because
the relationship they had led
grindelwald on a dark path
[Applause]
dumbledore is at war with himself
dumbledore and grindelwald made this
bond as young men and made a pact
through a blood truth
when you carry it you cannot go into a
physical fight with the opponent
so there was no way i could go into a
fight with dumbledore
they intend to turn you back on your own
kind
a big part of this movie is just
trusting dumbledore once again i miss us
too much of you right it was always
clear in the harry potter stories that
dumbledore's plan sometimes means not
knowing exactly what dumbledore has up
his sleeve but trusting him has newt
told you why you're here
was he meant to
no
newt has to go and accrue this band of
players but he goes in with an honesty
there is going to be an element of
chance here but have faith in me
because i have faith in dumbledore
we're here to see almost dumbledore
that would be my brother
in this movie we address the history and
trauma in the dumbledore family my
brother sacrificed many things mr potter
on this journey to find power
there's a very complicated brotherly
relationship with dumbledore and
haberforth and something to do with the
sister ariana hello queens credence has
been lied to
and misled dumbledore has to try and
tell credence the truth
what's really interesting with
dumbledore is the person who seemed so
infallible when we were first
interfacing with him is a deeply
complicated person
he's confronting old friends old foes
and also confronting himself
things are not quite what they appear no
matter what you've been told
[Music]
you